all right now following the signing of
the democrats tax the poor tax the
middle class and tax people on fixed
income and their massive spending bill
yesterday many in the media mob all of a
sudden they stopped describing the bill
as the quote inflation reduction act how
convenient now with many fake news
reporters referring to it as a climate
bill now
and by the way in what is one big giant
bait and switch and it all took place on
your back you the american people will
pay the price for example fake news cnn
reporter caitlin collins tweeted quote
senator manchin is here at the white
house for president biden's signing of
the climate tax and health care bill
prompting widespread mockery and get
this democrat richard neal of
massachusetts is actually promising even
more taxes in 2023 if democrats somehow
retake the house and the senate
including raising individual income tax
rates so just like we've been telling
you biden is lying always has been when
he says no one making under 400 000 a
year will pay more under his plan just
like he promised he wouldn't tax people
that make for under 400 000 a year this
bill taxes people making under four
hundred thousand dollars a year we know
from the joint committee on taxation we
know from 300 economists and even the
cbo did their scoring irs audits will
generate 20 billion dollars from those
making under four hundred thousand
dollars a year under this law which
means joe biden and joe manchin and
every democrat that signed on to this
all lied to you when they said there
won't be more middle class audits the
law also raises corporate taxes that
will be paid for by you the consumer
higher taxes on coal natural gas every
barrel of crude oil in the country
whether domestic or import imported from
some foreign country that probably hates
our guts that will be paid for all by
you west virginia you're happy with joe
manchin on all of this because uh the
energy sector is pretty important to the
state of west virginia the media mob
they are totally on board with biden's
lies as misdirection as abc news is now
directing readers to a calculator this
is designed by a far left non-profit
that suggests that americans will save
money no matter what their income level
that too is a lie here with reaction
former trump economist steve moore along
with fox news contributor joe contra
steve we'll start with you on the
economic side uh well number one this
bill broke the promise about taxing
people that make less than four hundred
thousand there will be audits on people
that make less than four hundred
thousand dollars um they're taxing every
american on top of the biden inflation
tax estimated for a couple to be sixty
eight hundred dollars a year so this is
what we have two thirds of the country
country living paycheck to paycheck what
are we attempting to get to 90 of the
country getting to that point
yeah look there's no question people who
make under 400 even people make less
than 250 000 they're gonna pay a lot
more taxes on this bill and there was a
very important amendment to the debate
in the senate sean
by senator crapo who said okay democrats
if you don't if you're not going to tax
people make less than 400 000 why don't
we have a rule that these extra 87 000
irs agents won't audit people with
incomes below 400 000 you know what sean
every single democrat in the senate
voted against that amendment so of
course they're gonna that's those are
the people they're gonna audit is the
people who cannot defend themselves look
the big companies like general electric
and disney and google they have armies
of tax accountants and lawyers same
thing with the
millionaires and billionaires they will
come after the low-income people and you
one other quick point shawn you talked
about the democrats switching their
argument because nobody buys this idea
that this bill is going to reduce
inflation but i'm not making this up
sean their latest argument that the
democrats are running around the country
saying is that this bill is going to
make america energy independent come on
we were energy i worked for donald trump
we were energy independent when trump
left office the reason we're not energy
independent today then why
yeah
why is he sending emissaries to
venezuela why is he doing another bad
iranian deal why is he begging opec in
saudi arabia that's just another lie let
me go to the media side of this joe
concha and ask you so it was always a
lie the inflation reduction act the bill
does no no such thing
it wouldn't have been difficult for the
media if if they care to tell people the
truth joe uh to look at cbo and their
numbers to look at the joint committee
on taxation and their analysis
to interview the nearly 300 economists
that were speaking out against this
saying it is going to increase inflation
not decrease it
they got away with it now all of a
sudden they're no longer calling it the
inflation reduction act why
sean it's amazing we're well past
talking about on this show
how the media is biased and obviously
cheering for one party and reporting
against another it's now outright
activism when you see the headlines go
from calling this the inflation
reduction act to the
democrats climate and health care and
tax bill right and not just one or two
reporters did this not just one or two
news organizations across the board as
if almost a memo went out instructing
them we want you to call this this for
now on just like they did with ron
desantis down in florida and calling
that the don't say gay bill when uh that
bill didn't mention the word gay in it
once a couple of months ago it's it's
all the way it's going now at this point
and look
we can hear all we want from the
president as far as i'm not going to
raise taxes on anybody uh you know
making less than four hundred thousand
dollars a year we're supposed to believe
the guy and the administration that once
said inflation was transitory that was
last year then they said that oh no
actually it's vladimir putin's fault and
the invasion of ukraine then they said
and this was just last week that we're
at zero percent inflation that argument
is so ridiculous it's like saying our
economy is is being diagnosed with a
104.1
degree fever and then a couple of uh
days later it went down to 103.6
as far as a degree fever and therefore
there's no more fever we're healthy
again no of course not we're still very
sick because our inflation is at 8.5
percent so
to a point that was seen by charlie hurt
in the last segment in the end it comes
down to inflation the midterms
everything comes down to that and you
could spin it all you want and call it
whatever you want that's what it comes
down to and people are still feeling the
pain of it sean if james carville and
the clinton people were right it's the
economy stupid
these policies what impact does it
ultimately have steve moore will give
you the last word on the economy in
relation to the lives of the american
people
well joe is right is it's this inflation
is just a killer it's what destroyed
jimmy carter when he ran against ronald
reagan and lost what 45 states or
something like that so
but the important thing for people to
understand is the reason it's a lie that
this bill is going to reduce inflation
is because what caused the inflation in
the first place sean was the three
trillion dollars the democrats spent and
borrowed last year that's what lit the
forest fire and this year already that
when you include this bill plus that 200
billion dollar corporate welfare bill
they passed a few weeks ago that's
another trillion so can you believe this
in what 20 months
biden has spent and borrowed 4 trillion
that's as much as we spent to
fight world war ii for goodness sakes
yeah it's not going to end well it
already is not working well for the
american people two-thirds of americans
now live paycheck to paycheck and you
know what they just taxed america and
they lied about it you know my kids
would get in trouble it usually wasn't
what they did that got me more mad it
was when they say uh dad i swear i
didn't eat the cookie i mean while
there's cookie all over their face i
said stop insulting my intelligence
anyway thank you both steve moore joe
koncha hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else